You know,
in the history of our industry,
there have been some real major events
that have transformed the industry and
had a huge impact in our lives.
The invention of the integrated circuit
really opened up a huge number of
opportunities to do things that were
unimaginable back then than the creation
of the personal computer.
The PC.
That was a huge impact on our lives,
not only in our own personal lives,
but in the way industry conducted itself
and how they use computers to do the
things that were important to them.
Then the third thing was the
introduction.
Of course,
if they internet,
I mean that Internet with pcs and the
integrated circuit.
You can see how old that is building and
and changing the world.
I believe that the next step is going to
be what's called cognitive computing
because technology has changed so much
that we have not so much power in our
computing capability and so much memory
that we can store that we're able for
the first time to actually create
products that begin to mimic how the
brain works and what that means is that
the product can actually on a very
narrow,
particularly expertise,
could be as narrow as let's say weather
forecasting for example,
or something very narrow that the
product begins to learn.
I see these youths in and in a way that
means he has some cognitive capability,
so the more you use it,
the better it becomes at a particular
function to the point.
It actually gets to a point where he
begins to actually ask questions of.
You.
Think of it as a child.
You know when a child is born a,
their brain is empty,
begins to get filled with stuff.
Hopefully mostly good,
but when it comes to a point in time
when the child touches a hot plate and
the mother says hot,
then the child knows from then on,
every time somebody says hot,
he better be careful because now his
program in his brain and he's learning
continues to learn.
But there comes that time in the child's
life that all of us that have been
parents either dread or look forward to
is when the child starts asking why,
you know,
when you do something and say why,
why,
and where the child is doing is
learning.
He now has enough cognitive capability
to understand enough of what's going on
but not enough so that he laughs.
Why?
Well,
in the same way these circuits get to a
point where actually they begin to query
back and say,
I need more information.
Give me more information.
Tell me about this.
And uh,
there are some experiments going today
on healthcare,
in oil exploration,
in financial transactions where they
actually begin to tap the power of
cognitive computing.
And I believe that when that happens,
we're going to enter an era of that's
unimaginable today.
And in some ways is kind of exciting to
think of the fact that we could,
surrounded by intelligence that helps us
make our lives better,
but it's also somewhat frightening.
And the fact that you're now surrounded
by intelligence that begins to think
they know more than you do.
And,
and,
uh,
but we're moving to that direction.
I see it happening.
I think we're about 10 years away from
that being a real commercial reality.
However,
the work I've seen done in healthcare in
oil exploration and financial
transactions tells me that this thing is
very real.
And I'll give you one small example of
how powerful it can be.
A cannot disclose the names of the
companies,
but in one particular example is they've
looked at the data on a particular
medicine that was used to,
you know,
to treat patients.
And the way things had been done up to
now is you get a medicine,
you get FDA approval,
and then you put it out and then you
collect data and about 10 years later
you say,
you know,
I'd,
we're going to take the medicine off the
market because it's causing some major
problem.
Um,
well they took an example like that and
say,
let's pretend that we had this cognitive
capability back then and fitted the data
that we had and see what happens.
Well,
this actually cognitive machine was able
to predict within a matter of weeks of
the product being on the market,
what took 10 years of collecting data so
you can see how powerful something like
that could be.
And what he does is because the
computing capabilities so fast and the
amount of memory so large in a very
narrow segment,
it can do what let's say 10,000
people would do if you could get them
all together in one room to look at one
problem.
And so it is,
I see this to me,
uh,
as a next revolution in technology and
will impact everything that we do.